And that's why I so often make movies based on real-life events.
I look to history not to be didactic, 'cause that's just a bonus,...
...but I look because the past is filled with the greatest stories that have ever been told.
Heroes and villains are not literary constructs,...
...but they're at the heart of all history.
Love, support, courage, intuition.
All these things are in your hero's quiver,...
...but still, a hero needs one more thing.
A hero needs a villain to vanquish.
And you're all in luck.
This world is full of monsters,...
...and there's racism, homophobia, ethnic hatred, class hatred,...
...there's political hatred, and there's religious hatred.
And to me, and I think, to all of you, the only answer to more hate is more humanity.
We gotta repair.
We have to replace fear with curiosity.
"Us" and "them," we'll find the "we" by connecting with each other.
And finally, I wish you all a true Hollywood-style happy ending.
I hope you outrun the T-rex, catch the criminal...
...and for your parents' sake, maybe every now and then, just like E.T., go home.
Thank you.